Let's say we've
got a company here
that has exactly four shares
just to simplify things.
Obviously, very few companies
have only four shares,
but this will simplify
the explanation.
And let's say that
each of those shares
right now they're
trading in the market,
or I guess we could say
the last transaction that's
occurred in trading
in the shares,
they're trading at $2 a share.
So the market is saying
that each of those shares
are worth $2.
There's four of these
shares in total.
And we're going to assume
that this company has
no liabilities.
So the shareholders just
outright own the assets.
So if there's four of
these shares times $2,
the market is saying that
this company's assets are
worth exactly $8
right over here.
The market value of the
assets is the same thing
as a market cap in this case
because we have no liabilities.
Now what I want
to think about is
what happens if the company
wants to raise some more money?
Let's say that they want
to issue some more shares
and sell them to raise
some money to buy a factory
or whatever.
So what they literally
do is the board
approves for them to literally
create two more shares.
So now they have a total
of six shares outstanding.
And then the company goes,
they get an investment banker,
and they do a secondary
offering in the public markets.
And they sell these
incremental shares.
And they're able to
sell them-- let's
just say for simplicity--
at $2 per share.
Normally when you increase
the supply a little bit,
you won't get quite what the
previous market value was,
but you get roughly $2
a share for simplicity.
And by selling two shares that
it just created for $2 a share,
the company is able
to raise another $4.
So the whole reason why I'm
going through this exercise
is to ask a question.
Did dilution take place?
And there's different
ways to think it.
When you think
about dilution, it's
like you could imagine
if you have a sweet syrup
and if you add water to
it, it becomes less sweet.
Each kind of a cube of that
water, each drop of that water
has less sugar in it.
You've diluted it.
And so there seems to
be an analogy here.
We now have more shares
for the same company.
And it is true.
If you are the
owner of this share
over here before the
share offering up here,
you owned 25% of the company.
After the share
offering, you own 1/6.
So after, you own 1/6
or approximately 16%.
So it looks like the percentage
that you own of the company
has been diluted.
And that's true to some degree.
But sometimes the dilution
takes on another meaning,
that somehow because
more shares are
being used for the ownership
of the same company,
that maybe these
shares are worth less.
And that's the one thing
I want to challenge.
There is dilution in
the percentage you own,
but there is not dilution in
what the shares are worth.
Because before, if you had four
shares representing something
that is worth $8, now
you have six shares
representing
something that is $12.
Because the company didn't
just issue these shares
and get nothing
in return for it.
It got $4 of cash.
You can't debate the value
of $4. $4 are worth $4.
So now the assets of the
company are worth $12.
So you have $12 of assets,
no liabilities, six shares,
$12 divided by six shares
is still $2 a share.
So the value per
share has not been
diluted, just the
percentage of the company
that you happen to own.